[Musique]
on croit que dans les villes de province
il ne se passe jamais rien c'est faux
prenez orléans sa cathédrale saint
jeanne d'arc ses rues bien tranquille et
salwar majestueuse et écoutez bien cette
histoire
puis en raconter quoi exactement ambac
avait une femme cavité dring avec tettey
qu'elle était pour acheter pour l'argent
ni laïque avait dit qu'elle était
séquestrée
d'ailleurs finalement précisé quand même
beaucoup d'autres magasins belges en
magasin mais parie que tout le monde en
a parlé en lice a couru pendant la
majeure que ça correct
[Musique]
en ya 40 ans il s'est passé quelque
chose d'absolument énorme d'incroyable
eliane klein avait 22 ans et cette chose
énorme et a détruit certaines vies je
dois dire qu'il ya des gens qui ont très
mal réagi quand mal supporté c'était
quelque chose qui brisait vraiment tout
ce qu'ils avaient construit tout a
commencé au mois de mai 69 un secret que
l'on se raconte entre filles dans les
cours de récré une camarade de classe
m'avertit en me disant tu sais voilà ce
qui se passe à orléans des magasins sont
incriminés dans la traite des blanches
et aux forges est averti et à ce moment
là plusieurs camarades sont approchés
elle nous avait avertis à nous a dit
surtout je vous dis ça uniquement pour
que vous n'alliez pas tout seul il faut
absolument vous y alliez avec des
parents ou accompagné se déroulait sous
forme de petites conversations
particulière de de secret qui se serait
glissée dans chaque oreille qui aurait
été répétée par tout le monde malgré
tout c'était des petits clans qui se
formait de 2 ou 3 et qui se raconter ça
[Musique]
c'est donc ça à orléans le bruit court
que les femmes disparaissent dans les
cabines d'essayage de plusieurs magasins
des magasins tenus par des juifs
on leur ferait des piqûres elle serait
droguée puis conduite par des
souterrains jusqu'à la loire où
attendent des sous marins qui les
emmènerait dans des pays lointains pour
les livrer à la prostitution
e
ça m'a paru tellement fou j'élabore riz
et je suis parti au collège où j'étais
propre à l'époque et je les dis aussitôt
à une une amie et quand je lui ai dit ça
elle m'a dit pourquoi je te croirais toi
et ça a été comme un déclic je me suis
dit mais qu'est ce qui se passe là ils
devaient être six heures du juin rue de
la république en plein centre ville et
je tombe sur le chef de la police locale
henri blanquet été journaliste à orléans
il avait visiblement envie de parler et
j'en profite je lui dis ah bon et pas la
justice y aspirent à elle me dit je
viens de rencontrer le procureur et qui
voulait à tout prix me faire dire qu'il
y a eu des enlèvements à orléans charbon
et me diouf et nous avons entendu parler
de ça vous les femmes qui disparaît
[Musique]
dans la ville on ne parle que de ça la
rumeur est dans les salons les
entreprises les administrations
elle courait en fle tout au long du mois
de mai jusqu'à ce samedi jour de marché
le samedi 30 mai devant l'autre magasin
la foulée sa tribu que se passe-t-il
les gens n'arrêtent eux il n'arrête pas
de passer en famille et des dizaines et
dizaines de personnes
là-bas en place
partout nous montre du doigt nous
assumons
et nous envoyer des grossièretés ce mac
user tous les goûts la police est formel
aucune disparition de femme n'a été
signalé dans les trois mois précédents
les gens seraient ils devenus fous
orléans est elle une ville à part il est
temps de chercher des réponses
dans tout le folklore européen on a
c'est 7
comment dire manière de raconter des
histoires d'horreur d'enfants disparus
barbe bleue c'est ça ça remonte à la
nuit des temps mais c'est bien la même
trame narrative pascal froissart et le
spécialiste des rumeurs une légende se
réactualise et se relocalise en
permanence en revanche l'histoire elle
même elle reste relativement similaires
selon les époques selon les lieux et on
retrouve donc cette rumeur d'orléans
dans d'autres lieux qu'à orléans et même
ailleurs qu'en france je pense que la
proximité de la crise de 68 et pas
totalement étrangère à cette poussée à
la fois antisémites et surtout
fantasmatique jean garrigues étudie
l'histoire du 20e siècle on a une
société malgré tout qui est déboussolé
ce c'était qui sort d'une crise qui
remet en cause les fondements de la
société avec notamment la place de la
femme au coeur de cette nouvelle société
à bâtir est incontestablement que le
fantasme s'accroche comme ça sur la
traite des blanches sur ces femmes qu'on
envoie je ne sais où
eh bien ça ça dit quelque chose d'une
société qui est en train de se reformer
de se re formule à la fin de mai 69
eliane klein dont les parents sont
commerçants à orléans contacter un
journaliste parisien claude angeli
aujourd'hui rédacteur en chef du canard
enchaîné mais parker se trouve ça fou
mails ne pas me sens le communiqué du
préfet qui est obligé de rassurer la
population il n'y a pas de disparition
on ne peut que croire une chose pareille
un communiqué officiel dix ans c'est une
rumeur il ya pas de disparition et
toutes plus en plus mais messi qui
disparaissent dans les cabines
d'essayage la piqûre est ou non
au départ on dit
les magasins jouissons sont accusés de
traite des blanches
j'imagine pas c'est que la traite des
blanches ne pratique pas comme ça le 2
juin les commerçants visés par la
calomnie porte plainte
car l'histoire de traite des blanches a
des relents d'antisémitisme
la riposte s'organise la presse s'empare
de la faire
la rumeur d'orléans devient un scandale
national
le fantôme du juive qui dans le monde de
chrétien occidental est celui qui fixe
une angoisse qui prend en charge la
culpabilité est finalement qu on va
sacrifier comme bouc émissaire ce
fantôme du juif commencent à sortir des
profondeurs où on le croyait à jamais
enfouis
alors c'est ça à mon avis le terrain
favorable de cette rumeur n'était pas le
toffee sémitisme nazis bien sûr c'était
quelque chose qui remontaient peut-être
moyenâgeux et déviée croyances mais
c'est toujours inquiétant de voir que
le travail n'a pas été fait pour
éliminer toutes ces traces
d'antisémitisme
oui l âge de 10 ans ses biens aux
commerçants juifs que la rumeur
s'attaque ici
mais ailleurs le même scénario vis
d'autres communautés l'étranger fait
peur et dérange alors comme le bouc
émissaire de la femme enlevée savent
très bien faire des demandes
bon la réaction très intéressante de ce
monsieur dans la principale rue
commerçante de d'orléans il est très
représentatif de cette opinion de ce
monsieur tout le monde puisque bon il
nous dit tout ça relève finalement d'un
règlement de comptes entre commerçants
mais en même temps il emploie un
vocabulaire celui des israélites qui
renvoie très directement au vocabulaire
de l'entre-deux-guerres et de
l'antisémitisme de l'occupation et que
nous montre bien que il ya quand même
des relents racistes dans cette affaire
est que ces présents au coeur même de
l'inconscient collectif orléanais
il l'a raconté à moi il ya donc
l'antisémitisme est assez symptomatique
à orléans mais pas symptomatique pour
l'ensemble des rumeurs qui ont la forme
de la rumeur d'orléans en corée puisque
j'avais remarqué ça encore et cette
rumeur la même histoire d'un choeur les
ans a couru mais c'était évidemment pas
les juifs qui est incriminée c'était les
japonais à chaque pays
à chaque époque son bouc émissaire mais
partout c'est le même scénario
le bruit enfle et se répand comment
l'arrêter démentir c'est encore en
parler et ne rien dire c'est toujours
cautionnées
faire quelque chose c'est à dire par
exemple démentir c'est le meilleur moyen
d'augmenter la notoriété des rumeurs
c'est à dire diffuser l'information
auprès de gens qui la plupart du temps
n'était pas au courant et qui du coup
quand ils reçoivent cette information
non non non ceci n'est pas vrai vont se
mettre à douter
ou en tout cas vont se mettre se poser
des questions
si la rumeur est le plus vieux média du
monde aujourd'hui elle emprunte d'autres
chemins
elle court sur les bouches mais aussi
sur la toile à vitesse sur multiplié les
rumeurs courent toujours et elle cours
d'eau de plus en plus vite dans la
société d'aujourd'hui la société
internet la société de la communication
monde
ce qu'on peut penser simplement c'est
qu'une rumeur chasse l'autre aujourd'hui
et au fond cette rumeur d'orléans qui a
occupé les premiers plans de
l'information pendant quelques semaines
là elle aurait été très très vite
remplacé par autre chose et peut-être
que ce cette psychose collective
finalement leurs épaules temps de se
développer tant l'information
aujourd'hui est banalisée par sa
récurrence et par sa fréquence
extrêmement rapide
désormais tout ce qui est sur internet
c'est gravé à jamais on ne peut plus il
n'y a pas de faculté ne comment dire
d'oubli ou de d'amnisty sur internet
donc on retrouve des vieilles rues main
vous des vieux récits des vieilles
histoires des vieilles blagues des
années 2000 qui sont relus par des
internautes des années 2009 2010 et qui
vont être probablement copier-coller
assez facilement alors probablement dans
un premier temps sous la forme du
commentaire du genre à regarde ce que
j'ai trouvé sur internet
et puis c'est les précautions verbal
peuvent disparaître au cours du temps et
de la des reprises et puis faire
ressurgir des rumeurs dont qui ont 10
ans d'âge
la rumeur n'est pas seulement un bruit
qui court c'est aussi un bruit qui
détruit à l'intérieur de façon
insidieuse une blessure dont on ne se
remet jamais complètement
quand ils se considéraient comme à
l'heure actuelle comme citoyens à part
entière devant la loi ou simplement
serons-nous toujours des juifs
elle a changé mon regard justement sur
la société
ça a été d'abord un peu d'effarement et
puis après donc la prise de conscience
de la nécessité de s'engager quand il y
avait vraiment des choses importantes
qui se passait dans le pays ou ailleurs
d'ailleurs pas que d'un pays donc
c'était aussi un peu à l'origine de mon
disons militantisme
c'était grotesque mais plus c'est gros
et plus ça passe les gens manquent et
c'est pas nouveau
singulièrement d'esprit critique et
croit tout ce qu'on leur dit et j'avale
tout alors y compris des sous marins qui
remonte la loire vous voyez la loire
comme elle est
quarante ans après la rumeur d'orléans
est encore l'exemple cité par tous les
chercheurs en communication la première
légende urbaine disséqué par les
sociologues dans un célèbre ouvrage
d'edgar morin
quarante ans après les histoires pour se
faire peur ont toujours autant de succès
on en trouve toujours
alors elles n'ont pas toujours la même
forme la rumeur d'orléans a à ma
connaissance ne court plus sous la même
forme
mais on trouve toujours des histoires
d'enlèvement est plus que jamais
aujourd'hui la rumeur est toujours là
elles changent constamment de visages de
lieux de cible elle est même revenu à
orléans
comment vous n'étiez pas au courant il
paraît que jeanne d'arc louis jeanne
d'arc
eh bien elle n'a jamais existé
[Musique]